étrangère
[Musique]
il est venu me voir avec une boîte
nous avons commencé à me dire de la colère dans un but très réel
qui est de préserver l'histoire et de
donner la possibilité aux Jeunes
Apprenants de la rencontrer face à face et de
s'immerger dans  son histoire,
nous croyons que l'histoire n'est pas quelque chose
qui appartient au passé, nous croyons que
l'histoire est quelque chose que vous pouvez vivre
dans le présent et nous utilisons donc
la vidéo conversationnelle comme un moyen de pouvoir
parler de l'histoire à travers les gens
qui l'ont vécue
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
étranger
[Musique]
l'invitation